e e
good
morning it being 10:00 I will call the
fiscal committee meeting to order for
September 13th
2024 first item on the agenda is the
acceptance of the minutes so
Move Motion by Senator gray second by
Senator um dallesandro to accept the
minutes as written is there any further
discussion seeing none all in favor say
I I oppos
no am minutes are
adopted abstain minutes are
adopted and she wishes to be recorded as
abstained okay we don't have any old
business we're moving on to tab three
and there is um a consent calendar that
covers tabs 3 through 7 the house has
asked to be removed under Tab 7 item 281
and
284 are there any requests for removal
from the
Senate seeing none I'll let entertain a
motion to adopt the remainder of the
consent calendar with those two
exceptions Senator dallis Sandro moov
Senator bird sell seconds to adopt the
remainder of the
calendar any further discussion seeing
none all in favor say I I oppose no that
motion is adopted so we'll go to Just
delandro yes move the second alesandro
and bir silers
okay now we'll go to tab
seven and look at items 281 and
284 beginning of the
cab both items deal with the Department
of Health and Human Services and we see
the finance officer Mr White is here
I'll recognize
uh representative f for
questions himself all right we'll let
him introduce
himself morning members of the committee
uh Nathan white Chief Financial Officer
with the Department of Health and Human
Services thank you thank you Mr White
for being here so in your not your but
in the comments and the note it
indicates that
the
uh the population of people not are
still ined has gone down by about half
over the past year and the weight time
has dropped by about half over the past
year and you or somebody was kinding
enough to provide me the pointer to your
online charts and it seems that those
numbers were as of May and if you look
as of today it's gone back up again both
the uh numbers of people in the uh
emergency rooms and the length of stay
that they're there and Mr M if you had
anything to say about that if you can
speak to that
so um I I believe this was in response
to fist
24281 um which was the New Hampshire
hospital I I think initially where we
responded um and and we did provide an
overview uh just for everyone's
Awareness on the committee we did
provide a link to a dashboard online
that is for Mission zero which is the
state's effort to get weight times down
to zero um I mean we we certainly see
fluctuations in those numers on a
day-to-day basis um but overall the
trends have been pointing in the right
direction um are you referring to like
most the most recent numbers that you
were saying were going
up right so I'm referring to the the
page you sent me to the link you sent me
to yeah there's actually three tabs you
can choose from the middle one seem to
be the one that related to the numbers
of people in the emergency departments
awaiting a bed
and the and it seems to be a one-ear
span basically from last September to
this September and it shows as you just
indicated and it has two things it has
the absolute numbers and it also has the
rolling 30-day average and in looking at
that as you just indicated the the trend
was down starting last September all the
way until I believe May both in terms of
the absolute numbers and the rolling uh
average but since May it has gone the
other way it's been trending up not not
to the original place it was a year ago
but maybe halfway back up if you will
sure and halfway down in terms of that
Del the time they're spending
there what specifically are you looking
for a comment on the
trend um so I I I don't have the numbers
directly in front of me to to that
analysis um I can go back and take a
look at that and provide more thorough
commentary on those numbers but I I'm
I'm not looking at them directly in
front of me and I think there may be
other factors that play as well and I
think I would need to check with uh the
experts in the field just to make sure
that we can provide you with a
comprehensive answer okay thank you
followup follow up um so on a separate
note related to this can you provide us
the contract the farum contract you
referenced when if it's available or
when it becomes available sure the the
the farum contract that we're currently
working on that that we're asked to
being extended here the Authority for
this B yes absolutely we can bring that
forward and those metrics uh once we
releas that to the governor executive
Council but it's currently under
development thank you of
course further questions on item
24281 seeing none I'll entertain a
motion to adopt
it motion by Senator delandro second
by representative f um further
discussion seeing none all in favor say
I I oppose no the item is adopted moving
on to item 2 2428
84 I believe
it's representative F again has a
question
yes so a couple of questions here
um well I guess the first one just the
easy one how much money is left to be to
be expended that we
extending the date for I I I would have
to go back and get that figure uh ju
just to look at what's encumbered what's
been spent year-to date and what's
available but I I can provide that to
you pretty easily okay and thank you and
the other question is so I asked about
the Medicaid rollof to which you
responded with a very excellent
description um but one of the things you
put down that was not applicable and yet
if I go back and look at the the
referenced notes from prior years that's
exactly what's referenced in those notes
and I guess I'm just curious as to you
know you sort of had these pools of
money and then they get expended in
different ways now the call center thing
was in all of them but so is Medicaid
roll out so I don't think it was
completely inapplicable to ask about it
because there was no reference in here
to that no longer being part of the need
for the
funding
okay so so so is your question will this
funding be needed in the in the future
because of the because the Medicaid
unwind is primarily complete is that
your question I guess I make it as more
of a statement perhaps if you don't
intend to
use funding for purposes for which it
was priorly said it was being used for
and they extending that funding that you
would just indicate that that funding is
no longer NE that component is no longer
needed to be funded sure so the um the
call center currently Fields calls um
and often deals with calls for people
calling about
eligibility uh we are including a
prioritized need in our next budget for
this purpose to continue funding the
call center because if if we do not have
a call center that's funded eligibility
um staff will likely be increased with
additional burdens which could increase
weight times which may have an impact on
anybody seeking
Services of course for the questions on
item
284 representative Earth
moves representative Bradley seconds to
adopt item two 4
284 further discussion seeing none you
ready for the question all in favor say
I I oppose no the item is adopted moving
on to the regular calendar under Tab
8 first item is Department of
Justice um
money and request for money for
litigation
expenses representa lean moves to adopt
is there a
second second Senator Bradley further
discussion seeing none all in favor say
I I oppose no the item is adopted moving
on to tab
nine item 24303
any discussion Senator Rosen thank you
um I do um have a couple of questions
this
is as I understand the
narrative this is about the
transitional path program housing for
individuals who are leaving New
Hampshire
hospital it seems
like we had money and Behavioral Health
for this program but we also made a
house bill
to appropriation to the vendor n fi
North would it be a fair
characterization to say that we double
budgeted These
funds and now the department is
transferring one bucket of them to
elsewhere no um so I can provide a
little bit of History just for all of
the members and I'll directly answer did
you say no I said no um and and I can
directly answer your question Senator
Rosenwald uh so for context in the fall
of 2020 the Department of Health and
Human Services uh opened up the uh path
transitional housing program uh for
individuals that were exiting New
Hampshire hospital beginning in uh
January of 23 uh following approval of a
contract in December by GNC with NFI
North uh NFI North uh took over
operating uh the the facility at that
point in time um as ref as Senator
rosenal referenced during the budget uh
in nhp2 chapter 79 Section
504 uh it it carry forward funds that
were previously appropriated um via 91
section 408 laws of 2021
and it expanded the purposes for that
and within that was transitional housing
and part of that as a goal of reducing
the emergency department wait times um
and the the division for and and the
reason we were seeking that was at that
time was because it was I mean it was
more of a dynamic situation that we were
trying to solve and we were also rolling
out Mission zero at that time because
that Amendment uh component happened
during the Senate phase um which was
also around the time that uh litigation
was pretty active as well so it was a
direct response to that so while there
are other funds budgeted in dbh those
have other purposes and earmarks if
you'd like I can provide um I can
provide you with a plan for the general
funds that we do have budgeted uh for
the other contracts if that would if
that would give you um a a a better
explanation into detail you're seeking
just to just to verify that it's not
double budgeted I that would be helpful
but could I follow up thank you so um
the the federal court order and this
really goes back to representative
Earth's question about ER boarding gave
the state until May of this year
to um get any individual with certified
iea out of the air within six hours we
are not yet doing that are we
we tell people waiting longer than six
hours I I'm I'm not directly involved at
that level of detail I can certainly
reach out to the individuals that are
monitoring those those details on a
closer basis and give you a follow-up
explanation if that's helpful but I I I
prepared more so for the financial
component today less for the litigation
uh that I don't necessarily think I
should be commenting on you're just the
person in front of us
thank you thank you Mr
chairman further questions on the
item seeing none is there a motion to
adopt Senator Bradley moves Senator
dallesandro second to adopt the item
further discussion seeing none all in
favor say I I oppose no the item is
adopted moving on to Tab 10
the item Senator Bradley moves the item
is there a second second from Senator
dandro any further discussion Senator
Senator
rosenwall good morning morning Sarah
Stewart commissioner of the Department
of Natural and cultural resources and
I'm thrilled to be here this morning for
Jace Worth's first fiscal meeting
congratulations yes it's a big milestone
in anyone's life
um uh J low
expectations congratulations
congratulations um Jace comes to us with
a um a wonderful background in outdoor
recreation in the ski industry and he is
our new JD if you remember JD who ran um
frankonia Notch State Park in Canon
Mountain for 16 years um so I'm I'm
thrilled to to introduce you I'm just
going to let J briefly introduce himself
and then we can get into any questions
you have good morning everyone it's a
pleasure to be here so I'm originally
from Steamboat Springs
Colorado um I've spent 14 years uh in
the industry coming from the private
sector I built my career um on
transforming independent Resorts and
I've delivered uh dramatic improvements
in financial results operational
efficiency customer
experience um most recently I served as
general and of grany ranch in Colorado
um Sim similar in size and scope to
Canon Mountain Fran Con not State Park
um and I'm I'm looking forward to the
project presently at the mountain um
we're getting ready for Fall Foliage
coming up already the leaves are
starting to turn um but we're in a
little bit of a breather here over the
next 10 14 days until we see the um
wonderful crowds come in we're also
preparing for the winter and um I've
hired a number of key positions but
right now we are uh Full Tilt headed
toward winter um so with that you know
we've submitted um our pricing uh
recommendations to the committee and
seeking your approval on
them look forward to your changes and
also you will find it much more colorful
foliage in New Hampshire having flown
over the mountains in Colorado they'll
be all green on one side and all the
other one another because it tends to be
monoculture on each side of the mountain
but it's not that way here
questions Senator rosenell thank you
um it's difficult to read this small
type
but as I understanded if you are a New
Hampshire senior resident and you want
to ski at Canon on a
weekend and you buy your ticket online
you're getting a 21% price hike and if
you're going to the window the day you
want to ski it's a
24% price hike could you explain why
that's appropriate please sure that's
that's a great question um first of all
I'll couch that in terms of all of the
products um I think when I came in in
late March um certainly we a little bit
in assessment mode as we evaluate the
fiscal year 24's budget deficit um
presently over the last 3 years we've
seen uh a dramatic increase in costs
upwards of 11% in trailing threeyear
average with only about a 3% growth in
revenues so um a pricing study was
conducted I looked at our demand as well
and so all of the products that you see
here I factored in a number of
implementations to drive additional
revenues including to the New Hampshire
resident
products thank you um I think I heard
they you're pretty new to the state and
the area um so are you aware that two
years ago we increased the prices on
seniors by about 30% so in the
last two three years we will have up the
prices for seniors to ski at a state
park by like
50% yes uh I'm I'm aware of that I think
what's um important to consider it's
been a part of of my study right now if
you can picture a particular day at the
mountain um only about one fth of the
skiers on the Hill are actually on full
price paid tickets and so the outcome of
that is you know Canon overall um
benchmarks lower than industry average
as it relates to revenue yield per skier
visit um the rest of the skiers on the
mountain on that particular day ma'am
are um season passholders and you know
split pretty evenly between season
passholders and then all folks who were
on heavily discounted programs so as I
was evaluating demand as I was
evaluating products I certainly looked
for areas number one um from a whole
love business standpoint how can we
drive additional paid ticket visitation
to increase our revenues and then also
where are some of those ways that I can
you know if if it's not just a a full
penalty on New Hampshire residents I I I
don't want to be interpreted like that
but what are some of the ways that we
can just um overall increase Revenue
yield per ski visit and that was one of
the considerations to that final Follow
by really more of comment it just seems
like you're doing it on the backs of
seniors thank
you Senator Bradley for a question uh
thank you very much my three sons live
in Steamboat you probably knew oh
wonderful yeah um I'm glad you're you
know looking at the fee structure for um
skiing at Canon Canon is um way under
price compared to other um areas in New
Hampshire and certainly Steamboat
Springs I believe is like $150 or
something like that for you know if I
may it's actually $300 to ski yeah so on
a day really congratulations um it's
long overdue and my understanding is
seniors in New Hampshire still get a
weekday discount that's pretty
significant so I congratulate you thank
you further questions on item 301 I have
one Mr chair chairman and we have
representative Lehman thank you Mr
chairman welcome to New Hampshire uh so
I was looking at the military day pass
increase and I see that online now is
$58 and the advanced or online purchase
goes to $79 which seems rather a steep
climb for those that have served in a
military and a benefit that we've
provided for
years may I react um two important
considerations so a key implementation
that um uh you you'll find here in this
menu is the implementation of variable
pricing which is a common tactic used by
virtually all um ski resorts in North
America Europe Etc and what it does is
we're looking for opportunities to
increase Revenue yield per visit where
we see price more price in elastic
demand so on your menu you'll see um
standard rates and then Peak rates right
there on those days that I've listed
below those are where we see more price
in elastic demand and where those price
increases uh price tiers take um
precedence and and that's where we would
seek to uh boost that yield so for most
of the days of the year it's only about
20 25% of our operating days for the
vast majority of the Year military
one-day lift tickets will be $64 in
advance and then $84 at the window um
and then during those Peak period times
where we see the greatest demand that's
when it would be $79 and then $99 at the
window further question followup thanks
Mr chairman so financially how do you
stand it's always been a struggle to
make ends meet and I see you're raising
about
$400,000 with your proposed fee
structure MH so how does that put us
financially it's a great question so
first of all we're working with
approximately about a $1.5 million
budget deficit from prior operating year
um a couple of impacts um there was a uh
unfavorable utility contract um that
took place in the last two years it took
our uh electric rates from 7 cents a
kilowatt hour to 21 cents um it had a A
$700,000 plus uh net negative impact on
the budget and that's a large
contributor um to that deficit we have
re renegotiated that contract or should
I say dis has renegotiated that to more
favorable terms now we're at
01387 so um we've already taken out um a
large part of that deficit upwards of
600 to 700,000 a year there with some of
the cost control methods and some of the
Contemporary best practices that I've
implemented we will be expected to save
um at you know somewhere in the
neighborhood of 300 to 400,000 um in
costs on this particular upcoming
operating year and then this kind of
completes the puzzle on the revenue side
is where can I meet that next you know
400 500,000 to balance the budget at the
end of the day these are Baseline
figures too if there there's a real
correlation between
snowfall um and increased visitation
snow fall and increased yield so um I'm
optimistic that with a a good snow year
knock on wood um that uh our revenues
will advance Beyond this um but I think
it's a starting point from cost control
methods a renegotiated utility contract
and then targeted price increases thank
you thank you Mr
chairman further from the
committee Senator gray uh so what you
said and what I heard okay what I heard
was we are trying to shift the uh
veterans and we're trying to shift the
elderly into a slower period of time
where they would get a better discount
is that correct that would be one way of
interpreting it
yes
thank Senator birel it's already we've
already got we've got a motion to
approve and
all in favor say I I oppose
no wish to be
recorded thank you it's an impressive P
first
performance going to tab 11 got an early
item or late item rather but it's the
earliest of the late
items number 24
298 Department of Transport
ation moving some money is there
a is there a motion to
accept move by Senator Bradley second by
Senator Dallas Sandra to adopt the items
any further discussion seeing none all
in favor say I I oppose
no the item is adopted before we move to
the information items we have
a another group of late items that we'll
be discussing Senator Bradley Senator
greay uh I do want to talk about late
items before we get into the individual
ones uh this time I've got 12 on this
list and I've got one even beyond that
and when I got these I got these
yesterday afternoon okay uh getting that
many items that short of time before
uh the meeting uh does not give the
senators or the representatives enough
time to delve into these issues as much
as they
can that does two things that either
says well gee we close our eyes and we
push the button yes you know to vote for
them or we table them and I do expect
that there will be a motion to table at
least one of these items because of that
so the deadline for getting to the
committee members needs to be like noon
time on Wednesday for even items that
are going to be late except in very rare
circumstances and I certainly trust the
chair to approve those that are those
very rare
circumstances but again just as a
general statement that's the the feeling
expressed by the Senators when we met on
these items is that there's just too
many that are laid out items that if we
had gotten them like I say by noon time
on Wednesday it would have given us time
to interact with the commissioner on
those items and figure out what's going
on I know some of the other Senators may
want to comment forther
comments Senator delis thank you Mr
chairman I I I don't want to be the dead
horse but indeed the senator gra has
made a a I think a very worthwhile
comment you know you know how diligent
we are in looking at these things and
get getting into these things and you
you know by the quality the questioning
that you you Reed that people do their
research they want to know what's what's
going on and there are huge sums of
money that are now moving and if you if
you don't know where and and when and
how it it becomes problematic not only
to you but to the constituency that you
represent and it's it's it's it's very
very it's very important that we get
these items in a timely manner uh and I
know it puts a heavy burden on you as
chair to we accept them because that's
that's the way it goes that's the way
this committee is
structured but indeed I think all
entities uh should be aware of the fact
that that late items should only be
considered an an urgency or an as needed
basis and and that's that's the key that
the the the success of this this
committee because it proves that we've
done our worthwhile you know due
diligence in terms of examining these
items and and that's it's a key Adam a
lot of things happen here uh we spend a
lot of money here we appropriate a lot
of money here and uh I I think uh
knowing the full array is is very
important so I support Senator Senator
Gray's comments and uh and I I
understand the difficulty but indeed I
impress upon people that the budgets are
getting
bigger the items are more
complex uh and we don't have large
staffs to do research on this we do it
ourselves so indeed if we don't get the
items in a timely manner it creates a
problem for all of us and and I think
that's uh that's problematic because we
want to do a good job thank you Mr chair
thank you Senator Bradley uh thank you
very much while I agree with both of my
colleagues I I also want to give a shout
out to commissioner Caswell um the fact
that you know we're under and gopher is
under so much pressure to get these
funding items funded so that we don't
have to give you know this money back to
the federal government that's where the
pressure is coming from so um we
obviously need as much time as you can
provide for us but you deserve a shout
out for you know making this happen too
so I think we just have to deal with
what we have to deal with so anyway
thank you
Taylor
further the blame lies with me when I
get requests for late items I almost
always accept
them This was later than usual
but when I'm looking at arpa items which
we've all dealt with there's very few of
them that we really find fault with
because we know that these things are
shifting all the time he's he's going
through thousands of requests all the
time he's full-time reviewing all these
things and seeing which one is most
deserving and he does a pretty good job
of bringing us the ones that we would
probably all approve of but we're going
to see another pile next month because
that's a deadline and so I thought it
would seem better to try get some of
them out of the way this meeting because
I know we'll see more in October and
hopefully we will have a little more
time but again he's right up against the
deadline he's gotten information at the
last minute well we can't spend this
because we got disapproved for that and
so things are churning all the time and
and I was just trying to be helpful uh I
know I put all of us under some strain
but I thought you know if we could look
at it the night before and and still
have a good idea that it would be a good
idea to get them out of the way in
September before we get another slew in
October I apologize for the strain has
put anybody on so if I could just add to
that no apology necessary you deserve a
sh out too so I mean you're doing what
you have to do as chair and I appreciate
that thank
you representative um and then
Senator yeah I I I just want to say as a
former Army budget officer at the end of
every fiscal year there's a a a crisis
in trying to make sure that you obligate
all the money so I appreciate the stress
that this uh this these programs have uh
created in order to get the communic
ation and the and the approvals needed
so so I do appreciate that I I just
would ask that uh in the in the hurry
and the rush of the days to come in
particular that we maintain a sharp
discipline as sharp as possible around
using this one-time money for one-time
Investments and not go the easy route to
slip some of this money into uh ongoing
operations because uh there's going to
be a bill to pay for that in the coming
years if we if we artificially feed
operations now with one-time money so so
that would be my encouragement is to at
the working level maintain that
discipline onetime money for one-time
expenses thank you Senator G I just want
to go back and and clarify if I'm not
opposed to late items themselves but
when we get a late item if you get it
after say noon time the senators get it
after noon time on Wednesday that is
when we generally review these things
and have the uh comments uh given to LBA
who can interact with the agencies and
get us back the thing okay so there is a
big difference between receiving the
item at noon time on Wednesday and
receiving the item o Dark 30 on Thursday
okay there's a a big difference when
research that you can do and questions
that you can ask to be able to do that
so it's not that we're opposed to all
the late
items okay and there are going to be
ones that come in even Friday morning
but we need to keep those to the
minimum and give us the time to research
the ones that so when I look at the list
of 12 I won't go to the 13th one but if
we look at the list of 12 how many of
those could we have actually had
Wednesday at noon time so again just all
right for what it's worth I didn't
realize that you were meeting that early
this week in the future for October they
will not be accepted after noon on
Wednesday for late items
so anything
further let's move to the first item on
the uh arp
late item list 312 24 312 is New
Hampshire Department of Agriculture
markets and food any questions on this
item going attain a motion to
approve motion by Senator Bradley second
by Senator Dallas Sandra to approve item
24312 further discussion seeing none are
you ready for the question all in favor
say I I oppose no the motion is adopted
next item is
24313 Department of Safety move
the uh motion by Senator Bradley second
by Senator uh rosenal to approve item
313 any further discussion seeing none
all in favor say I I oppose no that is
adopted moving on to item number
314 Department of Safety again the item
Senator Bradley moves the item Senator
dallesandro seconds further discussion
seeing none all in favor say I I oppose
no that motion is adopted moving on to
item
315 emergency relief and Recovery move
the item Senator Bradley moves the item
Senate rosenwall seconds is there any
further
discussion seeing none all in favor say
I I oppose no that motion is adopted
moving on to item
316 from the emergency relief or
the ARA ARA more ARA funds uh any
further discussion move the item Senator
Bradley moves the item sen
um bdel second it for item 316 any
further discussion seeing none all in
favor say I I oppose no item is adopted
moving on to item
317 this is uh emergency relief and
Recovery is there any further discussion
on this
item Senator Bradley moves the item
senat rosemal seconds any further
discussion seeing none all in favor say
I oppose no items
adopted and one exstension Senator
dallis
Sandra moving on to item
318 Senator Bradley moves the
item Senator birdell seconds further
discussion seeing n Senator rosenal I I
do have a question okay for the
Department well actually
for I don't know if it's for Nathan or
for commissioner C I'll I'll try Senator
so thank you the explan
says this is the first of its
kind
um living arrangement in the
state but um there is a contract with an
organization called Community Options
that operates 10 homes or 12 in New
Hampshire three of which are in nashwa
four individuals with develop mental
disabilities so I'm not
sure how this is different that makes it
the first of its
kind um well I would have to say that um
I can't confirm that it's the first of
its kind that would be something that we
certainly went back and forth with uh
the sponsor of the or this organization
and that was information we get so there
might be some distinction that I am not
familiar enough with to speak to today
but um I guess I would just put asterisk
nness to that statement perhaps my
Nathan
no um I I I I do not know the nature of
the request or the specific project
that's planned but you you are correct
we we have a $3.2 million contract with
Community Options for uh 32 beds in the
state currently that's active um but I I
don't know the specifics of this program
to be able to differentiate what's
unique about it we'd have to go back and
just verify that okay thank
you further questions move the item
Senator Rosell
moves it's already been done very good
all right all in favor say I oppose no
item 318 is adopted moving on to item
319 information
technology and any questions on this
item Senator rosenal has a question yes
thank you it's my day to ask questions
um and we see Mr Gay taking seat good
morning um Mr chair uh members of the
committee Dennis goule commissioner of
the Department of Information Technology
good morning good morning morning we we
do have a healthc care
Workforce problem in New Hampshire and
um we've looked did various
efforts to increase the pipeline of
people entering Health
Professions um from programs in Middle
starting in middle schools to rural
residencies towards more training for
nurse practitioners lots of ways to
increase the health care
Workforce and also we always look to
bring new doctors in
I guess my question is that um I'm
looking at the last paragraph on page
two which says the solution to this
backlog is to implement a new more
effective licensing
system and it's really more of a comment
I I mean I think this is good and it
will help but I think it' be naive of us
to think this is going to solve our
health care Workforce problem because
there are a lot of different things we
need to do this is one and it's good and
I fully support it but um I hope we're
not getting the public to think that by
making the software work faster we're
going to get people faster doctors
appointments or faster entry into
substance use treatment or mental health
treatment because I I don't think this
is the solution to that P I would agree
with that and and I I think the intent
of that comment and and I I apologize if
it wasn't clear it was the intent was
more around um the the accuracy and
timeliness um and accountability of the
process by which we vet and adjudicate
those those
applications uh that's we we intend to
to solve that or improve that a lot um
and I you know I've heard feedback
directly from individuals on the
experience and it's and sometimes it's
not as good as it could be and then
that's what we you know the experience
of actually getting licensed and that's
really where where we're targeting
further
discussion okay I don't believe we have
a motion on this
item okay motion by Senator rosenal
second by Senator dallis sandria to
adopt item 319 there any further
discussion seeing none all in favor say
I I oppose no the item is adopted moving
on to item
uh I would actually to table
Senator Bradley moves to table item 320
second by
Senator
Rosenwald since that tabling doesn't
have
discussion we'll move to a vote uh let
Senator Bradley wishes to elaborate a
little more
okay want more
information motion to table we'll do it
by show of hands all in favor of tabling
raise your hand 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 it's
tabled okay item 320 is
tabled moving on to item
question okay motion by Senator Bradley
to move the item second by Senator
birdell and we'll have a question for
Environmental Services good morning for
the record my name is Susan Carlson
chief operations officer with the hampsh
Department environmental
services uh thank you Mr chair uh thank
you um I just want to confirm the my
understanding of the four projects and
the amounts Lake Massabesic for $3
million to raise the level of the lake
um which will obviously help the entire
water system of Southern New Hampshire
um $1.5 million for London der's water
planning that will um help the
groundwater trust fund save that money
$1.5 million for a uh water system in
Bartlet that has been the subject of
litigation for a long period of time and
then I believe it's
$109,000 for um a pump unit in the town
of Hudson you are correct those are the
four
projects yes they are okay very good and
uh again Mr chair thank you for moving
this one forward I think this is a big
item uh we put a lot of focus on water
in New Hampshire and I think all of us
um you know support that thank
you
okay question representative f for a
question thank you Mr chair in the
future could you in incorporate that
kind of information into your note
itself I was just thank you
you anything
further Iain a motion to adopt it's
already been done done okay all in favor
say I I oppose no item is adopted moving
on to late item number
322 everybody have
this this is kind of a
summation yes Mr chairman no that's
information but if the members have any
questions for the commissioner all right
this this is just an informational item
anybody have any
question all right seeing none we'll
pass over that because we don't need to
vote on it and the last item I show is
323 fishing
game 2 million uh
371,000 any questions on that item
this one needs needs a vote I'll move it
Senator Bradley moves adoption of 24323
Senator Del excuse me
seconds further discussion seeing none
all in favor say I I oppose no that item
is
adopted okay we've finished those items
and is there any before we move to the
audit is there any uh questions on the
information items after tab 11
all right seeing none we're ready to
move to review of the audit of
the uh State
Treasury welcome the state
treasurer Miss Mesa Pell
good morning Mr chairman good morning
and members of the committee for the
record I'm Christine Young director of
audits for the LBA we're here to present
our financial audit report of the State
Treasury for fiscal year
2023 Colin Quinn audit manager with our
office was the InCharge manager on this
audit he will present the report and
also joining us from the state treasury
is our state treasurer Monica mapelli
who will be available for questions and
uh with that I'll turn it over to Colin
for the presentation of the
report thank you Christine good morning
Mr chair and members of the committee
for the record again my name is Colin
Quinn and we're here this morning to
present the report on our financial
audit of the State Treasury for the
fiscal year ended June 30th
2023 this report is presented in two
sections the first section is the
management letter section prepared by
the Auditors and it contains our report
on internal control and compliance along
with three audit observations which are
Then followed by the current status of
Prior audit
findings the second section the
financial section contains our
independent Auditor's report followed by
the treasury prepared financial
statements and
notes the focus of my presentation today
will be on the observations and
recommendations however we would be
happy to answer any questions you may
have on any part of this
report if you turn to the table of
contents you will note that the three
observations contained in the report are
all internal control observations none
of which are considered to be material
weaknesses we did not identify any
observations related to State compliance
and treasury concurred with all three of
the audit
observations turning to page three we
included a table to summarize the
recommendations as requested by the
committee we have noted here that none
of the observations are identified as
suggesting that legislative action may
be
required the observations begin on page
four with observation number one which
recommends the treasury continue to
improve the record keeping for its
off-book accounts and prioritize
migrating the accounts to the state
accounting system the total balance of
the accounts at June 30th 2023 was
approximately $61
million these accounts are largely
accounted for on Excel spreadsheets
which increases the risk of error and
fraud as spreadsheets do not allow for
the robust control framework which is
inherent in general ledger accounting
systems such as the state system New
Hampshire
first observation number two notes the
debt management system used by treasury
during fiscal year 2023 was limited in
functionality was outdated was not
supported by the vendor requiring
significant staff attention to ensure
debt schedules were
accurate treasury entered into a
contract with a new vendor for a
replacement system in May of 2024 and we
recommend that treasury work with this
new vendor to ensure the new system
meets treasury's
needs observation number three on page
six recommends the treasury adopt
policies and procedures to document the
responsibilities of key employees in
order to provide for reasonable
continuity of operations in the event of
unplanned employee
turnover moving to page 99 the appendix
located be behind the tab on page nine
reports the current status as of
September 3rd 2024 of observations
contained in the fiscal year 2013 state
treasury management letter as noted on
page 11 12 of the comments were fully
resolved and one was
unresolved the financial section of the
report then follows with our Auditor's
opinion which was modified as a complete
set of financial statements was not
presented the governmental fund
financial statements begin on page eight
with the statement of revenues and
expenditures for the general fund
education trust fund and capital
projects fund the balance sheet and
statement of revenues expenditures and
changes in fund balance for non- major
governmental funds follow on pages 9 and
10 the fiduciary fund financial
statements are then on pages 11 and 12
with the notes to the financial
statements beginning on page
13 this concludes my presentation I
would like to thank the state treasury
for the assistance we received over the
course of the audit the treasurer and
her staff were very responsive to all of
our requests and comments we would be
happy to answer any questions the
committee may
have questions from the
committee comments from the treasurer of
course uh good morning Mr chairman
members of the committee uh for the
record State Treasurer Monica mapelli um
first I would like to thank uh the AUD
uh Christine Colin um the members of the
team uh Jean um Donna nick uh for uh
their um who were very professional I
want to thank them for their work and uh
of course they were very patient with us
while they were trying to um um they
were waiting for information from us um
uh for their audit so I want to thank
them for for that work and um so I would
like to uh start um you may all recall I
was once an LBA AUD so um I have uh um a
lot of respect for for the office and
the work that U mik um and his team uh
and everyone generates for the state the
state is very fortunate to to have the
Oba um and to have that work that they
that they did they produce for the state
um so uh the the other thing I want to
say is once uh about 10 years ago uh I
was sit and Collins uh chair I had the
opportunity to to lead the audit of the
last audit of the treasury
and um at the time it was when uh
treasure preventure was moving on and
and treasure d uh was uh uh stepping in
into that role and um I had the honor to
he he asked me to to be his uh deputy
and I had the honor to to join the
treasury um treasure DW was very
committed to resolve all of the
observations and one of my first
assignments was to work on all of those
observations so I'm very pleased to
report that we we resolved all of them
except for one and and that last one is
included in this report and it's
observation number one um so so with
that what I want to say is if I may Mr
chair I would like to just uh briefly go
over the
observations um so the first one uh um I
could say a lot of things where we
haven't um migrated all those accounts
to the accounting system but um what I
can what I would like to focus on today
is is really um that we uh to tell you
that we do have a plan to migrate him as
you all know the the the state is is
going through the process to uh to
upgrade uh the current accounting system
uh to uh to the cloud and so as part of
that new functionality uh that will be
available uh there's a there's a a
component of that new system that will
have a module that will have um it has a
dedicated space for thep these types of
accounts trust accounts so our intent is
to uh to migrate all those accounts uh
take the advantage of the full uh full
functionality uh Tak full uh advantage
of that functionality uh and again
migrate those accounts and and finally
um record and and and have the corporate
accounting for for this for this
accounts in in the accounting system so
we are mindful of all of those risk and
we have implemented controls to uh again
try to mitigate in the potential risk
that manual accounting um creates uh so
again we're mindful of that risk and we
have a plan to to um to resolve that to
to resolve that issue
uh the second observation I'm very very
pleased to say that we consider that
fully resolved we have implemented a new
debt management system uh as so as we
understand that system has um robust
internal controls we already using that
functionality we are um already using
the reports for um for the work that we
um provide for the preparation of the
financial statements for the AER and
we're also already use n for projections
for our budget de service projections so
we're comfortable with that um of of
course just needs to go through the the
process of being audited by the external
Auditors KPMG is going to look at that
um but again we're we're we're confident
and and I'm confident that uh we're
going to see a positive outcome and and
certainly the state we are in a much
better position today than we were uh
before we had this
system and the last observation um uh we
completely concur with the Auditors we
agree we need to have more to
documentation not only for what um our
lead uh and our key employees produce
but also so for uh core functions of a
treasury um it is um it is a real risk
to um the fact that when I look at my
staff I can see uh many retirements in
the future in the near future and so it
it's it's something that we're mindful
of and and we are not only uh this is of
course this is part of the solution to
have more documentation but also um our
goal is to continue to review the
structure our structure our processes to
ensure that we maintain a resilient
treasuries a treasury that can survive
all of us um so um again we'll we're
we'll be mindful we are mindful of this
risk we continue we continue to um uh
create uh more do documentation as as
recommended by the otter and obviously
that work will be ongoing and so we U
we're committed to continue that work
and um the last thing I want to say is I
want I really want to thank my staff um
here with me as uh Deputy Treasurer
Lauren Warner um in uh Forest for my
deputies uh also Rachel Miller Chief
Deputy Treasurer and and my staff the
treasure wouldn't be what it is today
and so very thankful for for having the
opportunity to work with them and I also
again I want to thank the audits for
their work um I feel like I passed the
test I'm not sure um but um but again
we're very committed to um to maintain
and I did I I am fully aware that I'm
I'm responsible for having strong
internal controls to to make sure we are
uh internal controls over um financial
reporting to ensure that we have we
protect our funds and and again I'm
committed to continue with this work and
uh we I'll be happy to answer any
questions thank
you questions representative Edwards and
then Senator D you know thank you for
this thank you for the audit uh I I'm
I'm I I'm focusing on the the third
recommendation about improving the
documentation of key
responsibilities to me that's been
critical in every role I've ever had to
be very clear on who was doing what and
but I but I understand documentation can
get out of date so what I'm really
interested in is you're you're
describing the environment in which your
agency is operating are you operating an
environment in which the uh rate of
change is so great that it's difficult
to keep the documentation current or are
you operating in environment where these
documents just um Drew in attention that
that you just assumed what they said
rather than reusing them at annual
performance updates
reviews thank you for the question
representative um so so you are
absolutely correct documentation can get
sailed very quickly and that's one of
the challenges I think um what we are um
what we again thinking about how we're
going to approach this and there are
some key key key pieces that we can
focus on uh um so for example uh believe
it or not there is no not a job
description of the treasurer so we're
going to start with you know key
components of documentation things that
are um you know you will consider um
critical any in any organization so um
organization started to change um a
little more again we're going to go
through uh a whole um upgrade of the
accounting system the work that the
treasury does relies on that system to
reconcile accounts to to receive uh
reports so um for over 15 years has been
about the same and so now we're looking
at our structure and trying to um again
trying to see what the future is going
to look like in a year or two and um and
you actually you you there are some
changes you may see in the budget
process in order to prepare for some of
those um some of those um changes that
we're seeing and again trying to prepare
for uh what we see as the treasury of
the future so so we're going to again so
we're going to try to um document key
pieces but it is um but you're correct I
think that think the challenge is going
to be try to keep up with that
documentation as we see the treasure
transition as we see the state uh
changing their environment technology
needs to drive what we do a lot of the
processes that we do are very manual we
rely on institutional knowledge of some
key employees um and and we just said
they're about to retire so we need to
revisit all of that and rely a little
more on um technology and then document
procedures based on those uh again what
around that technology and the key
functions of the treasury so um I'm not
sure if that answers your question I
think I think the the key the challenge
is going to be to stay current um but
also um again we want to move forward to
thinking about how the future is going
to look like uh and and just um update
those procedures as as as we change
so so what I think I heard you say is
it's a little bit of both that there was
the environmentally there was a little
bit of a lack of attention to the
documentation but more more importantly
as you go forward and you're innovating
at the the agency that that you have a
proactive requirement to to adapt to the
Technologies and the procedures and and
then clarify job roles as you manage
your change process that is is correct
and and so we do have a lot of
documentation of different things but
there perhaps and this is what the audit
the audit focused on is is to document
key key Concepts key procedures key key
things that are not documented so we're
going to focus on that and again try to
identify what it is that is critical
that we need to have documentation
on senator delandra for question Mr
Chief first of all mon I want to commend
you for a magnificent job I I look at
the focus every month and let me tell
you something this budgets balanced by
interest income and your management of
those funds makes that happen and I
Kudos that I've been around here for a
long time I remember when Bob Flanders
was our Treasurer now I'm probably the
only one around this table who remembers
B plan is maybe
uh okay here Jane does but uh and I used
to deal with him on a daily basis uh I
think the job you've done is terrific
uh as I say just people look at the
focus every month look at what's
happened look at that bottom line number
and you know that we're in Balance
because of that so kudos to the work
you've done and I think the thing that
we all should be cognizant of is the
number of retirees that will be
happening uh in the near future and
we've got to replace these retirees with
with very capable very competent people
and that's a tough job and uh that's a
very very difficult to do but uh it's
it's a it's an ominous responsibility
the retirements will be uh will be uh
something to look at and then you had a
tragedy in your office a person passed
away un very unexpectedly you had to
deal with that and and you did so Kudos
and I haven't seen an audit report as
good at this in a long time where where
all of the things are addressed so uh so
that Michael Kane must be a Dynamo with
the put putting the pressure on
but uh that's that's really magnificent
it is wonderful to see that to get a
report where everything has been done
and you you can't be that's good
government at work so kudos for that
thank you Senator thank you I'm going to
miss you Monica but I I've got to tell
you this that
$6.7 return I got because when when you
did the achievment process that was
wonderful that made the difference in my
budget so thank you very much thank
thank you Senator and we've been we've
been fortunate speaking of Interest
we've been fortunate to to to for a
period of time to have a very strong C
uh uh cash balance so uh and obviously
uh interest rates have helded so that uh
we we definitely took advantage of that
uh time uh times are going to change uh
but we we feel like we are um positioned
to to to to do better in the future uh
based on you know the opportunity that
we have some cash sitting in our bank
for some time so um as we've been here
and a balanced budget will be key to
this uh and U but thank you very much I
appreciate your kind words and I will
miss you
too
further how many employees do we have 22
in total we're 22 thank
you 22 22
employees representative f for a
motion thank you Mr chair actually two
motions so the first relates to the
financial report of the State Treasury
that we just heard I move to accept
place on file and release to the public
in the usual
manner all in favor I
I motions adopted any any negatives
no second motion un related to the
treasury okay um I'd like to make a
motion to accept place on file and
release to the public and the US ual
manner any audits which will be
presented at the October and November
fiscal committee meetings when available
I'd like to speak to my motion you were
recognized
so we currently release reports such as
the a for audit such as the acur um
ahead of time um independent of when the
fiscal committee meets and I'm actually
asking that we do that for all of our
audits at least the ones coming up in
the next couple of months here so those
that um work better with PDFs um can
have those AA available prior to uh the
meeting thank you second motion second
that we have all the um audits in a PDF
format anybody understand
that second it thank you all in favor
say I I oppose no that motion is adopted
now we talk about thank you excellent
results from all of you appreciate it
very
much uh future
meetings if we go to this third Fridays
and we try to schedule them two months
in advance we would be uh Friday October
18th
and November 15th for the third
Fridays if you could all note those down
and let me know if if
that's seems
acceptable we'll go ahead with the
October
one with without objection and be ready
for the November one as well I'll
probably not be able to
be we'll have a replacement I'm sure may
I ask a
question may I ask a question Mr chair
certainly okay the 18th is no issue for
me the in in November um what what are
what are what would be the possible
alternative dates given that that's
Thanksgiving month
is there an alternative to the
15 I think the I'm trying to look and
see when Thanksgiving
comes it's 28 28 so it's quite a few
days later and it'd be the it' be two
weeks later that we'd
have
Thanksgiving
so it it would be difficult to move it
later possibly earlier but
that kind of puts a cramp on things
October I expect as I announced we'll
have the the final on the arpa hopefully
I'll get it to you Wednesday morning the
latest and
uh and uh
November sometimes we have we make a a
motion for the cafer because it's it
might come up late in December I don't
want to have to hold that up I'm I'm
fine thanks for the discussion thank
you so without objection those will be
the dates for those
meetings is there any further
information to come before
us appreciate you all and all those of
us to one primary will be seeing you
again you're not running
again yes I've read that
microphone it was a good good Senator
good contributor who was also a State
Rep right and we uh on Ways and Means
send our sympathies to us feebly thank
you got to put that in the
record anything
further entertain a motion to
adjourn all in favor all right we are
adjourned thank you that was pretty
quick
e
e e